that case impression but I this year's
been like a dream for me a little more
than a year ago my life was very very
different and widow clear that morning I
woke up with a brain younger mr.
Fletcher what if biggest challenge and
adapting this immensely difficult
emotional challenging book logs book
sold from the perspective of a
semi-literate character and it has some
motifs that are quite difficult
unflinching eye color and Michael will
drop to try to honor the spirit and the
impact of the work as a cinematic and
accessible experiences and I fell in
love with this game character page one
or two and I think that was a big help
but it was also one of the difficulties
because I love you so much and we had to
put it through so much so people ask
about the difficulties sure I think
Albright hands didn't call
surely a book like this which I found
out after writing was considered an
adaptable but some of the difficulty was
years before I wrote storming pages of
original material and try to get any in
history so long and at the very end
synced vibe to this character I love so
much but again it was not challenging
feeling creative experience that I
congratulations the film is so visual
what sort of visual guide lights did you
have in the script early okay oh you
know this show really activated
everything that I ever learned or study
learn about and one of those areas my
love of the Old French Japanese an
Italian phones and when you have these
wonderful stories of these individuals
reversing the rugged terrain emotional
and otherwise and I'm quite training for
folsom NYU for graduate film I'm change
the director so when I looked at every
page of this book I have a filter on for
what can you dramatize visually what
cannot look cinematic what is not and so
I guess that back for longer
glugging predictions well a little
superstitious but if you look to my
right wow that's almost and what do I
predict why I predicted would be a great
night for everybody who goes and and I
just told my mother has a good time you
know and you know i'd be shocked that
mean I didn't know sports bras name when
it my name work home but again I think
it's gonna be a great night for for
everybody and I'm just so honored that
our film was recognized with with so
many nominations well lanique deserves
every honor she gets and a few others so
and as terms of what you brought you
know when you write these things you
envision the ultimate scenario and she
said that scenario in a way I've never
I've never seen in quite like that and
filmed before and odd others we
associated with her performance in this
film and I remember only the very first
on a matter of
hotel lobby and afternoon with Lee
Daniels when I remember I never met
someone so insightful so alert so humid
so fierce so warm and and you see it you
see some of her gears but she's got so
much more if you can believe it believe
it or not so I'm honored to endure
Oh